let me start by saying you haven't heard
me say this but congrats on the movie I
think it's so well done considering they
you guys made it for like a dollar fifty
in a roll of duct tape I'm so impressed
with what ends up on screen I'm sort of
curious jump in i I heard that you like
to improvise a little bit in the moment
so I'm curious how how did that work
because this is your first big you know
first movie working with someone who
likes to find it in the moment yeah I
mean he taught me so much about improv
and I really appreciate it because the
first time I worked with him he would
gosh ship and I was really confused I
was like I was waiting for my cue but
then I really learned how to just go off
script and kind of conversate in the
moment and it really helped me because
then I really realized that sometimes
it's okay to go off script it and
sometimes it makes the scene a lot
better and it makes it a lot more
realistic because you're not always like
oh what's my next line you're not always
thinking about that you're just kind of
going off script but still staying in
the subject so she taught me so much
about that and it's just the thing
really good movies are about great
conversation and if movies aren't
conversational then especially movies in
this genre and if you get the actors to
believe that they can just talk to each
other and look like they have
relationships with each other and then
you don't have a lot of exposition
explaining the relationship because you
get to see it and that's what they did
very well with their script and then
left us alone to have the relationships
and she gets it like that and she
obviously gets it like that and just
real real quick which is essential in a
movie like this because you're gonna
have so much stuff that isn't
controllable by conversation or anything
like that that has to look a certain way
and so forth the zone and this one is
amazing
the mother is amazing the real mother is
amazing
and it was fun that's the other thing
movies should be fun yeah and these guys
had fun I don't know if they had fun but
we are saying is if you do something you
love you'll never work a day in your
life that's very very true
guys words from an almost 10 year old
that's all so I'm going back to what
you're saying it's a lot of show me
don't tell me you know which which
always makes things better for each of
you talk a little bit one of the things
that really impressed me about this film
is the script is the story that they're
trying to didn't successfully put on the
screen for each of you could talk a
little bit about what it was about the
script that and the story that really
appeals you I think for me reading the
script it was about three years ago and
it was when this the first stuff was
happening with the wall and like were
you know all of the stuff that's
happening politically with sexuality
different cultures racism like it really
touches on those themes but in a
completely like non-political way and in
a genre that makes it really fun and
kind of you know like an adventure to
watch but and you leave thinking about
those themes automatically about like on
what's happening in our present-day
world but in a kind of a supernatural
sci-fi world and I feel like that's like
the power of movies is to tend to make
you think and you know escape but you're
escaping in a different world yet you
can relate to so much that's happening
in this world that was for me what I
really loved about the script for me
when my mom made me the script it really
touched me that Chloe has never been
outside because I love out the outside
and I really wanted I was really curious
because you know she's never been
outside and her dad's keeping her and uh
I was really asking myself what would I
do if I if I had never been outside and
my dad was keeping me out and then just
a whole adventure she goes through like
when she meets mr. snow cone and
everything just it really made me
curious and it really made me it really
made me want to get the part for me is
it was basically I am always excited
and how people look at me in the casting
business and the producing writing
business when they come to me and they
say well we want you you know well that
gives me a green light to say well they
know who I am they know what I bring
they know so forth and so on so we don't
need to go through all that but then to
have the ability especially when I never
knew either one of them before and I
just you have to trust them because they
don't BS you it's on the page and you
got to make that live a lot of movies
they don't live on the page and the
actors have to bring it alive well these
guys had a form and you had to bring it
live within that farm and they write
very good conversation full dialogue and
that was a big help to us plus the fact
this little one is a wizard
standing and it was just she was I you
walk on very few sets where somebody is
the magical light on the set well this
was that how much did she give you to
say that was it a dollar or five dollars
what was it was change we were in
Vancouver she needed aluminum for each
of you guys I'm always curious about how
people like to get ready to shoot
something so deep do each of you have
like a pre shooting ritual like
something you like to do before the
camera starts going me it's very simple
I had a director once said to me before
I did a movie form out
when we did Nebraska he said to me I
wonder if you do something for the
cameraman and I that we're not sure
you've ever done in your career I said
what would that be he said never show us
anything let us find it and that
immediately takes all the pressure off
you because you know you have a partner
and you don't have to show them anything
you can just behave have conversations
she had that naturally and she has that
naturally so it's it's you know it just
worked the chemistry was good but what
the credit goes to the two guys because
they knew that somehow before they
gassed us they knew that the math would
work you know what I mean sure
do you have any sort of appreciating
things some people I heard like like
music or you know they want quiet like
each person is a different thing I don't
stick to one certain thing and that so
many sets are so different some people
you're working with cast members who are
really loud and like or the crews I
don't know and I find the music could be
distracting I don't but I don't follow
it depends on what genre and you're
doing to like if you're trying to be
light and free I think as long as you're
in your body maybe some deep breaths
I don't know well also you are the
character so as soon as they begin I've
always started one real thing brings out
a bunch of other real things if you
start on a false note so but I've always
taken when somebody said to me why did
you ever leave the theatre why I started
on the contractor mr. Kazan so I started
in Braun Broadway and I came to movies
and I realized that they said well why
don't you go back to theater wine that
makes us forever
and Kazan always said to me he said no
when you get out there men in the
Hollywood you know don't ever tell a
director what you're gonna do before
take one ever I said well how am I gonna
get away with that he said very simply
because he's got something you will
never have I said what's that take two
done the first time it's gonna be there
or they'll do it again another way but
at least because if you go up to these
people and the directors or writers and
say well I like to do this or that
they're gonna hate it no matter what
they're gonna hate it doesn't matter it
is so you can't tell them you just have
to show them and do it and it's
spontaneity and forever for an
eight-year-old kid to understand that
what spot ahead is it's the easy I mean
kids can be the best actors you'll ever
work with if they just leave themselves
alone and don't try and perform you know
because you're hired because you're you
and we don't want you to be Shirley
Temple we want you to be you and that's
what you picked up real quick on that
note Congrats on the movie wish you guys
nothing but the best thank you for
giving me your time thank you